Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire sitting in
for David Pakman today. Don't forget, you can
follow me on Twitter, Facebook and Instagram at
fair and balanced. You can find me on YouTube at
youtube.com slash fair and balanced and of course,
the big channel youtube.com slash the Ring of
Fire, you know, according to the administration,
the Biden administration, America is no longer at
war, right? It's the first time we have officially
been at war in decades here in the United States.
But that's not true because there is a war raging
right now. And I'm not just talking about the
conflicts we're still involved in overseas,
I'm talking about the war here in the United
States being waged by Republicans. The culture
wars, the culture wars are pretty much the only
thing that Republicans have to run on these days.
And unfortunately, they're doing a dang good
job of it. Last Friday evening on Fox News,
host Tucker Carlson spoke with right wing radio
host Jesse Kelly, where they launched what is
really a new avenue in the culture wars that right
wing pundits have been talking about for the last
couple of months. And that is the emasculation
of the American military. It's too feminine,
they say, because, you know,
we've got women in the military.
We have members of the LGBTQ community in the
military, and Tucker Carlson and Jesse Kelly
just can't stand it because apparently that's the
worst thing imaginable. Here the two are talking
about what they perceive to be the problems
and, of course, their terrifying solutions
for the U.S. military. Take a look. I mean, I
don't know. There's a psychological term for
Speaker 3: this and it escapes my memory at the
moment, but where there's a massive real threat
that you can't deal with, so you scurry off and
deal with imaginary threats to make yourself feel
in control, that kind of feels like what
we're watching. Well, what we're watching
is the destruction of the U.S. military and what
we're going to end up seeing Tucker is thousands,
tens of thousands, maybe hundreds of thousands of
Americans die. That's those are the stakes of the
game we're playing here. We don't need a military
that's woman friendly. We don't need a military
that's gay friendly with all due respect to the
Air Force. We need a military that's flat out
hostile. We need a military full of type a men who
want to sit on a throne of Chinese skulls. But we
don't. We don't have that now. We can't even get
women off of naval vessels. That should be step
one. But most of them are already pregnant anyway.
Speaker 1: We want men who want to sit on a throne
of Chinese skulls. You know, what's really
interesting about all this China phobia
that's going on with the Republicans right now?
If you were to go out and ask the average voter,
the average conservative voter, what what's
the problem with China, right? What is the U.S.
really have against China? Why are all of these
Republicans always talking about China? All the
pundits China, China, China? None of them could
tell you why. Because it's a very convoluted and
ridiculous issue, and this, of course, builds
upon Donald Trump's trade war with China, which
for the record, we still don't have resolution
for that either. I would love to hear more from
the Biden administration about what they're doing
to undo that damage, but obviously they've got a
lot of other things to deal with. But let's
get back to the military issue, shall we?
Women who volunteer to go and fight for our
country, to sign up to serve the United States of
America, that's the problem. First and foremost,
let's talk about this. Is there a problem with the
military? Are we having an issue where we can't
win battles anymore, where we don't have the right
equipment, where we don't have the right training?
I mean, is that a thing that's actually happening?
Because if it is, I haven't heard
about this. I haven't heard about U.S.
troops just getting absolute destroyed and every
conflict we're involved in because of the women.
Or because of the LGBTQ community, that's not
a thing. OK, that's the most important thing to
remember when we talk about this is it's not real.
The U.S. military is not suffering. Because non
men are in there or because transgender men are
in there are transgender women, women. Anyone like
this is absolutely such a ridiculous argument from
these two that it's almost hard to even talk about
it because it doesn't exist, it's not real. These
are two absolute wimps that can't help themselves,
but from go around trying to act like we're
the biggest manly men ever. And by the way,
as Tucker said last week and David talked
about Cove, it apparently makes you feminine.
These people are the ones who are obsessed with
gender roles. These people are the ones who are
obsessed with pronouns and what you call other
individuals more so than anyone on the left is.
And of course, that's another one of the
big ironies of this. They claim that the
wokeness is so bad, you know that the pronouns
are bad, that transgender individuals are bad.
They're the ones who keep talking about it,
the Oh, the left only wants to talk about this,
let's do eight hundred segments on it throughout
the day. No, y'all are obsessed with this.
We just say, Hey, if somebody says columnist, call
them that, show them respect. Let's protect them
with legislation because they are being absolutely
targeted. You know, we see that in suicide rates,
we see it in murder rates, homicide rates, all
of that. This is a community that does absolutely
need legislation protecting them. But if you want
to talk about which party is going out there and
endlessly ranting about it, that's on the right.
That's not the Liberals, that's not the left,
it's not the Democrats, it's not the
progressives, it's the Republicans who seem
more obsessed with what is in somebody's pants
than they do with real problems that are actually
threatening the United States today. That's what
that's what I'm taking away from that segment.
But we also have to remember.
The Chinese skull comment, right?
That's horrifying. We don't want members of
the military who are bloodthirsty psychopaths.
But that appears to be at least in my opinion,
you know, my take away from it. What Jesse Kelly
is saying, we want people that want to go out
there and just kill as many people as possible.
And I know a lot of folks think that
that's what the military is supposed to be.
The military is supposed to be about
protection. The military is supposed
to be about fighting when fighting is the only
possible way forward. That's the way it was,
you know, throughout history. Sure. Of course,
you had people that abused it. Obviously,
they used it for takeovers. But here in the
United States, we're not taking anything over.
Our military is to protect us, not to go out
there and expand the American empire, although
clearly we've got plenty in power
that would love to see that happen.
We don't want a bunch of bloodthirsty, crazy
people out there running around the globe
killing people because they think that's what
conservative pundits want them to do, so that,
you know, attacking the not
more manly U.S. military
is apparently one of the new avenues and
the Republican right wing culture wars.